tony hamdoune avait 38 ans il était père
de deux enfants une vie encore rempli de
promesses interrompue brutalement par la
double explosion d'un port de beyrouth
mardi dernier aux premières loges dans
l'église orthodoxe aux côtés de ses
parents et sa veuve sa famille politique
nadim gemayel héritier de la dynastie
des forces libanaises a remis sa
démission du parlement la veille
c'est maintenant d'un choc politique
dont le liban a besoin
il faut en finir avec la domination
insidieuse du hezbollah dit il c'était
une c'était un tabou il y a déjà
quelques quelques jours même pas
quelques semaines aujourd'hui cela est
c'est le mot d'ordre qui est présent sur
la bouche de tous les citoyens
ils savent que leur hezbollah qui
directement ou indirectement est liée à
l'explosion qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
jours au port et cela est inacceptable
il a été rejoint par d'autres comme pas
là yacoubian une députée indépendante
on fait semblant qu'il ya une démocratie
dans ce pays quand il n'y a rien c'est
c'est ce parti mafieux aussi qui tient
le parlement un autre parti mafieux qui
était à la présidence un troisième
partie mafieux qui est bien tous et qui
protège ce système sectaire
ces voleurs des propos qui font écho aux
supplications des libanais lors de la
visite des manuels macron à beyrouth la
semaine dernière n'en voyait pas dead à
notre gouvernement lui ont crié les
libanais une garderont l'argent pour eux
à l'aube d'une conférence internationale
qui a accouché d'une aide d'urgence de
250 millions d'euros soit près de 400
millions de dollars
le président français a répété que tout
serait fait pour que l'argent serve au
peuple pour qu'une aide plus durables
soit débloquée les autorités libanaises
doivent faire des changements radicaux
prévient-il
il appartient aux autorités du pays
d'agir pour que le pays ne sombre pas et
pour répondre aux aspirations pour que
le peuple libéré exprime entre moment
même légitimement dans les rues de
gueule nous devons tous ensemble tout
faire pour que ni la violence ni le
chaos ne puissions pas la liste des
députés des ministres démissionnaires
continue de s'allonger mais c'est bien
loin de suffire
les demandes des manifestants qui sont
de retour dans la rue
le peuple sait très bien aujourd'hui que
c'est une bande d'incapables qui ne font
que de la propagande
les seules personnes qui sont en train
de reconstruire les maisons sont le
peuple
les seules personnes qui sont en train
de s'entre aider à distribuer de la
nourriture
c'est le peuple le gouvernement l'état
on ne voit personne alors c'est pas
difficile de se demander
ils sont où ils font quoi apparemment
ils ne font rien sur la route des
contestataires
il y avait en plus d'une importante
présence militaire des opposants civils
avec qui ils ont échangé des tirs de
projectiles
comme quoi le président a une et ses
partis alliés dont le hesbollah
jouissent encore d'un certain appui
populaire
on a souvent comparé le liban au phénix
qui renaît de ses cendres
mais eux en ont assez de rester fort
pour rebâtir leur vie sans arrêt
une chance de tout reprendre à zéro ne
sont pas éternels si marie ève bédard
radio-canada berry